ya hemos visto la reacción que convierte
al ciclo propano en propano y vimos que
era una reacción de primer orden y
también vimos que a 500 grados
centígrados la constante de velocidad es
de 6.7 por 10 a la menos 4 por 1 en 3
segundos en un vídeo anterior y ahora en
este ejercicio en el inciso a tenemos
que ver si la concentración inicial del
ciclo propano es de 0.05 molar cuál será
la concentración del ciclo propano
después de 30 minutos y lo que vamos a
hacer para resolver este inciso es
utilizar la ley de velocidad integrada
de esta reacción ahora como se trata de
una reacción de primer orden la ley de
la velocidad integrada o bueno una de
sus formas es el logaritmo natural de la
concentración del reactivo en cualquier
tiempo t es igual a menos la constante
de velocidad
por el tiempo que escogimos más el
logaritmo natural de la concentración
del reactivo al tiempo cero y en este
ejercicio el reactivo a es el ciclo
propano aunque hay 73 h 6 y entonces la
ley de la velocidad integrada para esta
reacción
y el logaritmo natural del ciclo propano
al tiempo t es igual a menos la
constante de velocidad de esta reacción
que la tenemos por aquí que es
6.7 por 10 al menos 4 y luego tenemos
que multiplicar esto por el tiempo pero
aquí nos piden la concentración del
ciclo propano después de 30 minutos nos
dan el tiempo en minutos mientras que la
constante de velocidad de la reacción la
tenemos en segundos entonces pues
queremos convertir a este tiempo a
segundos entonces tenemos por aquí 30
minutos y en cada minuto tenemos 60
segundos
entonces si multiplicamos 30 minutos por
esto de aquí minutos se cancela con
minuto y nos queda 1800 segundos
800 segundos 30 minutos son 1800
segundos que entonces ponemos por aquí
1800 segundos que es el tiempo que
queremos esperar y luego le queremos
sumar el logaritmo natural de la
concentración inicial del ciclo propano
great pero en este inciso nos dicen que
la concentración inicial del ciclo
propano es 0.05 molar ok entonces
tenemos que poner por aquí 0.05 molar
bueno lo que nos piden que encontremos
es la concentración del ciclo propano 30
minutos después queremos encontrar esto
de aquí pero pues tenemos este logaritmo
natural de aquí que nos tenemos que
deshacer de él para deshacernos de él lo
que vamos a hacer es exponencial a ambos
lados del igual
entonces la exponencial con el logaritmo
natural se cancelan y nos queda
simplemente la concentración de c 3 h 6
ciclo propano al tiempo te iguala 30
minutos y para obtener cuánto vale esto
vamos a sacar la calculadora menos 6.7
por 10 a lo menos 4 y eso lo queremos
multiplicar por 1800 y a eso le queremos
sumar el logaritmo natural de 0.05 ok y
finalmente queremos elevar a toda esa
suma y nos queda
0.0 14 es 9 que se redondea a 0 puntos 0
15 en la calculadora obtuvimos que todo
esto de aquí es cero puntos 0 15 y
sabemos que son molares y esta
concentración es el tiempo está igual a
30 minutos ahora en realidad no era
necesario utilizar precise
de esta fórmula también podríamos haber
utilizado la fórmula de la concentración
como función del tiempo que ya vimos en
otro vídeo aunque hay también podríamos
haber utilizado la fórmula que nos dice
que la concentración del ciclo propano a
un tiempo t es igual a la concentración
inicial del ciclo propano o sea cuando
el tiempo es igual a 0 por el ala menos
k t qué bueno si haces algunas cuentas
puedes observar que esta fórmula se
deriva de esta fórmula simplemente
tomando la exponencial de estos dos
lados del igual que hoy vamos a hacer
básicamente esto pero de una forma un
poquito más simplificada entonces la
concentración del ciclo propano al
tiempo t igual a 30 minutos es igual a
la concentración inicial del ciclo
propano que lo que nos dice este
ejercicio es que es
0.05 molar y la multiplicamos por el
elevado a la menos la constante de
velocidad
es 6.7 por 10 a lo menos 4 sea 6.7 por
10 a la menos cuatro por el tiempo
estamos en t igual a 30 minutos pero 30
minutos es igual a 1800 segundos
entonces pues vamos a sacar la
calculadora y nos tiene que quedar
exactamente el mismo resultado que
ponemos menos 6.7 por 10 a lo menos 4 y
eso lo multiplicamos por 1800 y elevamos
a la eso y nos queda
punto 299 y eso lo queremos multiplicar
por punto 05 y nos queda punto 0 14 9
que otra vez se redondea como 0.0 15 ok
esto que tenemos aquí nos dio
exactamente el mismo resultado la
concentración del ciclo propano al
tiempo t igual a 30 minutos es igual a
cero punto cero 15 molar bueno entonces
vamos con la siguiente pregunta nos
preguntan cuánto tiempo se tarda la
concentración del ciclo propano en
llegar a 0.01 molar y bueno para
resolver esta pregunta
otra vez realmente no importa cuál de
las formas de la ley de velocidad
integrada utilicemos entonces pues voy a
utilizar la primera aunque hay que nos
dice que el logaritmo natural del
reactivo
a un tiempo t es igual a menos la
constante de velocidad por el tiempo más
el logaritmo natural de la concentración
del reactivo al inicio la concentración
inicial aunque esta es la forma de la
ley de velocidad integrada que vamos a
utilizar y vamos a sustituir toda la
información que tenemos en este
ejercicio a ver veamos aquí lo que
queremos saber es el tiempo que cuánto
tiempo se tarda la concentración del
ciclo propano en llegar a 0.01 molar
entonces sabemos que en el tiempo que
nos interesa que todavía no sabemos cuál
es porque es justo lo que queremos
averiguar pero en ese tiempo la
concentración del ciclo propano es de
0.01 molar así es que tenemos que
sustituir 0.01 molar aquí entonces
tenemos que el logaritmo natural
0.01 molar tiene que ser igual a menos
la constante de velocidad de la reacción
que como vimos el inicio del vídeo es
67 por 10 a la menos 4 y eso lo estamos
multiplicando por el tiempo que queremos
encontrar más el logaritmo natural de la
concentración inicial del ciclo propano
pero la concentración inicial del ciclo
propano
0.05 molar así es que con un poco de
álgebra podemos despejar a esta te y así
ya encontramos el tiempo y listo para
despejar a te ponemos por aquí tenemos
el logaritmo natural de 0.01 y luego le
restamos el logaritmo natural de 0.05 y
dividimos todo eso
entre menos 6.7 por 10 a la menos 4 pero
necesitamos más espacio estamos
dividiendo entre menos 6 puntos 7 por 10
al menos 4 y eso es igual a t que es lo
que estamos buscando y bueno pues
entonces vamos a sacar la calculadora
ponemos por aquí el logaritmo natural de
punto cero uno menos el logaritmo
natural de 0.05
eso lo dividimos entre menos 6.7 por 10
al menos 4 y nos queda 2400 2.15 y el
tiempo es igual lo redondeamos a 2402 y
pues como aquí tenemos la constante de
velocidad de reacción en segundos
entonces estos de aquí son segundos y lo
podemos dejar en segundos o lo podemos
convertir a minutos acá y entonces
cuántos minutos son estos lo puedes
hacer en tu cabeza o podemos sacar la
calculadora que ahí tenemos dos mil
cuatrocientos dos segundos y lo
dividimos entre hay 60 segundos por
minuto estos segundos se cancelan con
estos segundos de aquí y 1 entre 1 entre
minutos nos dejas simplemente minutos y
por aquí 2.402 entre 60 pues ahora si
sacamos la calculadora
tenemos aquí 2.402 y lo dividimos entre
60 nos da aproximadamente 40 entonces es
aproximadamente 40 minutos
la concentración del ciclo propia no se
tarda aproximadamente 40 minutos en
llegar a una concentración de 0.01 molar
bueno ahora vamos con la siguiente
pregunta cuál es la vida media del ciclo
propano y para contestar esta pregunta
tenemos que recordar el vídeo pasado
nunca y la vida media denotada como un
medio para reacciones de primer orden
que es justo este tipo de reacción que
estamos analizando el tiempo medio es
igual a 0.6 93 entre la constante de
velocidad de la reacción porque hay
entonces la vida media del ciclo propano
es 0.6 93 / y la constante de velocidad
de esta reacción es 6.7 por 10 a la
menos 4 por 1 entre segundos
entonces para calcular esta vida media
simplemente tenemos que sacar la
calculadora y ponemos 0.6 93 entre 6.7
por 10 a lo menos 4 y nos da mil 34
punto 33 aunque hay entonces la vida
media del ciclo propano es mil 34 y aquí
tenemos 1 entre 1 en 3 segundos y nos
queda simplemente segundos que es lo que
nos debe de quedar así es que esta es la
vida media del ciclo propano ahora si
quisiéramos la vida media en minutos
simplemente sacamos la calculadora y
dividimos 1.034 entre 60 y nos queda
17.24 aunque ahí nos queda
aproximadamente 17 minutos pero recuerda
que significa la vida media la vida
media es el tiempo que se tarda un
reactivo en pasar de la concentración
a una concentración de exactamente la
mitad de la concentración inicial aunque
hay así es que si empezamos con una
concentración inicial de 0.05 molar la
vida media es cuánto tiempo se tarda en
llegar a una concentración de 0.0 25
molar y lo que acabamos de calcular es
que se tarda 17 minutos entonces esta es
la vida media ahora si luego nos
preguntamos cuánto tiempo se tarda en
llegar a una concentración de la mitad
de esta o sea en llegar a una
concentración de 0.0 125 molar nos
estamos preguntando otra vez por cuál es
la vida media y pues son otra vez 17
minutos